mais le projet de réforme est donc comme
l'a dit notre reporter présenté en
conseil des ministres demain avant
d'arriver au parlement début février une
étape clé pour une réforme contestée
depuis maintenant cinquante jours sur le
fort sur la forme et sur le fond
évidemment aussi le projet divise
notamment les syndicats si l'âge pivot
été retiré provisoirement les dés sont
ils jetés la réforme suivra-t-elle son
cours quoi qu'il arrive c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
débattre nous sommes avec pierre roger
secrétaire national cf cgc sur ce
plateau bon ce soir angers merci d'être
avec nous à marseille en direct
elle a un trannoy professeur à l'école
d'économie d'aix-marseille bonsoir
monsieur trannoy merci avec nous en
direct sur un fait france également
depuis marseille donc une question tout
d'abord à notre invité sur ce plateau de
la cfe cgc on l'a dit qui demandent une
pause 1 après la mobilisation de
vendredi une pause dans quoi dans la
mobilisation tout en demandant toujours
le retrait du projet pour quelles
raisons cette requête de pause pour la
cfe cgc
la priorité ça toujours été de de
dialoguer chaque fois et dans les
semaines qui ont précédé cette
mobilisation
chaque fois que il ya eu des phases
ouverture on l'a on a fait une pause et
on a essayé de discuter malheureusement
jusqu'à présent
le discussions étaient relativement
stérile alors la conférence de
financement va s'ouvrir le 30 janvier
pour nous il est naturel en tant que
partenaire social de dire bon on va
participer franchement est complètement
à cette phase on verra quel est le
résultat à côté de ça vous imaginez bien
que nous allons nous avons déjà entamé
un salon de discussion maintenant avec
les parlementaires
et puis surtout pour répondre à votre
question oui le débat commence nous
attendons les mesures d'impact nous
attendons de recevoir le dossier qui
comporte pratiquement 1000 pages on va
confronter nos chiffres avec ceux
annoncés par le gouvernement
et là je pense qu'on va pouvoir rentrer
dans une vraie phase d'information et
d'explication auprès des français au
sens large qui aujourd'hui faut bien le
reconnaître ont beaucoup de difficultés
mais si vous regardez la presse et
notamment cette presse très récente
depuis quelques jours ont beaucoup
d'informations commence à se diffuser
dont on voit qu'en retour les français
commencent à prendre l'ampleur du sujet
qui est un sujet très très compliqué
alain trannoy recettes stratégie
effectivement du syndicat réformiste cfe
cgc marque un temps de pause peut-être
dans la mobilisation pour qu'enfin les
débats il est temps j'ai envie de vous
dire puisque ça fait plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années que c'était
supposé commencer pour qu'enfin les
débats commencent vous avez aussi le
sentiment vous que l'on commença à
prendre véritablement des choses
concrètes sur ce projet de réforme
effectivement parce que c'est une
réforme systémique
une réforme qui touche je dirais tous
les compartiments de la retraite tout au
tout et catégories de retraités possible
touche également les gens qui vont
contribuer et ceci pour les toutes les
décennies à venir
or en face de ce projet systémique comme
vient de le dire monsieur roger ce n'est
que ce soir que
le gouvernement sort un document de 1000
pages concernant les études d'impact
c'est à dire un bon combat blement
quelques années le coût financier de la
réforme
est ce que la réforme va être équilibré
financièrement
quels sont tous les quatre types crois
qu'il ya à peu près plus de 135 cas
types qui sont étudiées pour savoir est
ce que les gens vont gagner ou est ce
que les gens vont perdre à la réforme
donc c'est une réforme extrêmement
complexe c'est une réforme systémique et
pour l'instant il faut bien dire que le
gouvernement était assez avare
d'informations dont on comprend e lle
une angoisse dans le pays
évidemment il ya les gens qui protestent
mais il ya tous les gens qui sont dans
leur salon et qui se disent à quelle
sauce on va être mangé donc je dirais
que effectivement le débat ne commence
que maintenant et on peut se dire que
quelque part
ben sur les deux ans sur lequel a couru
des négociations n'ont pas la
négociation 1 et la discussion avec
entre le gouvernement les syndicats
il ya eu je dirais des moments qui n'ont
pas été mises à profit pour essayer de
faire avancer les connaissances
informations sur la réforme de leur
gouvernement avait en tête il faut bien
comprendre qu'en fait va apparaître
petit à petit un élément qui est passée
totalement sous silence pour la grande
majorité de la population c'est que le
grand gagnant de cette affaire on s'est
principalement l'état en tant
qu'employeur d'état en tant qu'employeur
dans cette opération
pour quelles raisons va est bien écouter
parce qu'aujourd'hui il était en tant
qu'employeur de la fonction publique est
un employeur qui payent beaucoup plus de
cotisations qu'un employeur dans le
secteur privé
suivant les secteurs ça varie entre 75
et 30% en moyenne
demain on a un système qui va qu'il va
faire que la fonction publique au sens
large va avoir un même taux de
cotisation alors ça va se faire
progressivement
avec le secteur privé donc on peut
penser a priori comme ça qu'on se dise
on va vers une forme d'égalité et c'est
ce que les français ont compris au
départ qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que le grand gagnant dans l' affaire
c'est que certes les hampes les
cotisations vont augmenter un petit peu
du côté et des salariés afin dé du
secteur public j'en parle des
fonctionnaires mais l'état lui va voir
son taux de cotisation pc 2 en moyenne
de 30% ce qui représente en lien à peu
près d'ailleurs ça commence à sortir les
chiffres sont sortis à travers les
premiers éléments c'est ce qu'on avait
estimé ses 45 milliards d'économies en
gros donc d'accord servira dé revenir
parce que les revalorisations qui sont
prévues sur le long terme ne concerne
que les les fonctionnaires qui sont les
dents les plus basses catégories et ceux
qui ont peu de primes et des professeurs
il ya une partie qui va être bien sûr
distribués mais le grand gagnant la
danse et le budget de l'état qui lui va
voir sa contribution baissé mais le
nombre de
retraités globalement lui va rester en
fixant un équilibre avec un budget à 13
14%
les français vont vite comprendre que
sur le long terme
la pension en moyenne des français en
terme de remplacement va diminuer et on
voit bien et c'est l'autre sujet quand
on parle du passage des 8 à 3 plafonds
que on va aussi vers un système qui
demain la répartition en france sera
beaucoup moins généreuse qu'elle ne l'a
été dans le passé
on va donc tout faire un changement de
système certains d'ailleurs l'on dit
traversent ou des interviews que vous
avez
présentée tout à l'heure chacun ne
l'expriment à sa façon mais eni vie ta
ble ment à travers les chiffres contre
ceux ci vont sortir et commence à sortir
il va y avoir cette découverte par les
français le bas le système qu'on leur
présente c'est pas exactement le système
par points universelles telles que il
avait été peut-être présenter au départ
est en tout cas que certains imaginaient
les économistes qui sont à l'origine de
ce système là aujourd'hui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans ce que présente
le gouvernement les des interventions
qui ont été faites de personnes qu'il se
cache pas d'être à l'origine de ces
propositions
on voit bien que bercy a pris cette
opération par opportuniste et d'ailleurs
les difficultés que à monsieur de le
voir à exprimer ce qu'il voulait faire
au départ il a été complètement barré
par bercy qui chaque fois il annonçait
quelque chose on va dire d'équilibré ou
de généreux le chiffrage qui était
proposée c'est qu'il a été obligé de
rester un peu quoi etc on aboutit à une
discussion à une absence de discussions
pendant deux ans monsieur delevoye a
même ni lui-même sa sa démission
plusieurs fois dans la balance
je vous rappelle qu'à l'origine on
devait avoir un système qui devait
pousser les français à travailler plus
longtemps en leur proposant une surcote
pour les inciter à travailler ce qui est
quelque chose que l'on peut comprendre
compte tenu de la démographie autres on
les passait un système de décote
on a parlé de l'âge pivot l'instaurer un
durée de cotisation de 43 ans qui dans
un système par points par nature n'a pas
de sens et donc le système a été
complètement dévié on arrive aujourd'hui
espèce de solution un peu compliqué avec
une conférence de financement dont on
voit pas trop bien comment ça va arriver
hier conférence de financement pierre
roger dans quelques instants d'un
trannoy sur l'analyse tout cas la
première partie de pierre roger ça sera
forcément un système moins généreux pour
les français
selon ce que vous avez pu lire ici ou là
l'économiste que vous êtes en pense quoi
alors il ya un point sur lequel je suis
entièrement d'accord avec monsieur roger
c'est le fait que on a vendu cette
réforme
d'ailleurs c'était dans le programme d'
emmanuel macron ont été candidats à la
présidence de la république
on a vendu cette réforme sous le couvert
d d'essayer d'établir une égalité
le mot égalité c'est pas exactement
l'équité donc en tout cas c'était plus
d'égalité dans le calcul de la pension
de retraite et à l'arrivée on se rend
compte et là il ya un certain nombre
d'études qui sortent en ce moment et qui
montre bien que cet objectif il sera
plus ou moins en fonction des
différentes concessions qui ont été
accordés un certain nombre de régimes
spéciaux sera c'est un objectif
d'égalité sera plus ou moins vérifiées
il sera peut-être un peu écornée mais
c'est surtout que est venue se rajouter
un autre objectif final gouvernement à
avancer masqué ainsi que le président de
la république on peut le dire puisque
c'était pas dans son programme
c'est en fait un allongement de la durée
du travail
je vous rappelle quand 80 françois
mitterrand a baissé la non la raab a
abaissé l'âge de 1 an on pouvait partir
en retraite de 65 ans à 60 ans avec la
réforme sarkozy on était à 62 ans pour
l'âge légal on ne discute plus de l'âge
légal mais on discute maintenant de
l'âge à partir duquel il n'y a plus de
décote
et quand on regarde je dirais les
différents cas types qui sont présentés
lorsqu'on les compare avec les retraites
qui auraient été assurés dans le système
actuel
eh bien on se rend compte que aux homos
d'eau pratiquement il ya il va y avoir
un recul de 3 ans de l'âge à partir
duquel on
on va pas prendre ta retraite sans
décote donc c'est je dirais la
superposition de ces deux objectifs qui
rend évidemment les français méfiant par
rapport à ce projet parce que en tant
qu'économiste bien évidemment on peut
dire que cet allongement de la durée du
travail est assez naturel vu les progrès
dans l'espérance de vie
oui mais c'était je dirais essai il ya
un certain angle on sait que la société
française
l'économie française a un certain nombre
de problèmes avec une dette élevée et
globalement on peut dire qui a pas assez
de travail
il n'y a pas assez de richesses qui sont
produits donc évidemment l'allongement
de la durée du travail si on arrive à à
ne pas garder des gens au chômage et à
les faire travailler
je parle évidemment pour des gens qui
sont pas sur des métiers pénibles qu'ils
sont en bonne santé
c c'est effectivement un projet pour
mettre de la richesse créer plus de
richesses et donc pour conserver un
relativement haut niveau de pension la
france a relativement à d'autres pays
européens sur la répartition au niveau
de tension donc en fait c'est ça la
solution proposée vers le sénat où on a
un petit divergences d'appréciation
jeu sur la première partie je peux je
peux comprendre ce que ce que vous dites
en revanche non il n'y aura pas au
niveau de pension il y aura surtout dans
ce système là le fait que l'état et il
est assez clairement indiqué dans le
rapport du cor que vous avez sans doute
pu lire six mois de novembre c'est
clairement indiquée pour la première
partie jusqu'en 2027
les fameux 12 milliards que la
conférence va chercher à trouver en
dehors d'un la solution inévitable
à mon avis d'un report de l'âge des
équilibres qui arrivera de toute façon
sous cette forme-là ou sous une autre
appellation de manière inévitable
c'est parce que il ya une baisse non pas
un problème de deux pensions à verser
mais une baisse des recettes qui
viennent principalement du fait que
l'état n'assume pas son rôle tel qu'il
l'a exister aujourd'hui l'exemple numéro
un qui est typique c'est la sphère des
gilets jaunes la non compensation des
cotisations sur les heures
supplémentaires
c'est un milliard en milliards de en
moyenne par an entre le mains et 2027
qui peu ou prou fait quasiment les trois
quarts du déficit des 12 milliards
quand l'état dit je vais réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires
donc je ne l'aurais pas à payer les
cotisations afférentes c'est un choix
politique c'est bien et le corps l'a
très bien exprimé il n'y a pas de
problème de financement des retraites il
ya un problème de simplement de
réduction des recettes et lorsqu'on
réduit entre temps les pensions de 8 à 3
places on chez les cadres que nous ne
réclamons pas on sait clairement dans
les notes de la chaire cargo qui sont
parus début janvier et qui sont commencé
à se répandre dans toute la presse et
qui est donc de journaux en ont fait les
échos c'est le cas de le dire
ces 4 5 milliards en moyenne par an en
moins de recettes
la volonté c'est clairement de faire
baisser le poids des retraites sur le
pib en france parce qu'il ya
effectivement d'autres choix de dépenses
qu'on souhaite mettre en oeuvre mais
c'est certainement pas pour améliorer le
niveau moyen des pensions
sur le long terme il y aura six millions
de français qui vont passer plus 65 ans
dans les années qui viennent à partir
moment au maintien et s'est clairement
exprimé d'ailleurs dans le rapport
c'est encore été dit la volonté des sens
de la part de des retraites à 11 tous %
en moyenne sur la durée mathématiquement
le taux de pension et la pension moyenne
sera à la baisse et c'est pour ça
qu'elle à côté on a mis la loi pâques
pour inciter effectivement à renforcer
tous les moyens de capitalisation ce qui
pose un autre problème par rapport
effectivement au choix français qui est
depuis 45 de la répartition et je
comprends que pour certains ce soit
troublant surtout pour ceux qui n'auront
pas les moyens de mettre de l'argent de
côté et malheureusement ils sont assez
nombreux
donc là encore en termes d'égalité on
peut s'interroger si vraiment ce choix
il est vraiment judicieux
alain trannoy rapidement la conclusion
puisque vous répondez pierre roger sur
ce plateau conclusions de ce débat alors
sur le dernier point concernant le fait
qu'il y aura effectivement plusieurs
milliards de d'euros de recettes en
moins du fait qu' on abaisse le plafond
de sécurité sociale enfin le délai
actuellement les quatre cotiser jusqu'à
8 huit fois le plafond huit fois le
plafond des tirs et socialement ils vont
plus cotiser pour leur retraite que qu'à
trois fois le plafond
il ya effectivement moins de recettes il
ya aussi moins de retraite contributives
au titre du site de la partition qui
seront versées à des cadres c'est un
choix fondamental est clairement ça n'a
pas été discuté suffisamment avec la
monsieur roger représente un syndicat
qui il ya beaucoup d'adhérents de cadres
et donc ça n'a pas été discuté ci vise à
man dans la société française c'est un
choix effectivement important car ça
favorise forcément pour en tout cas les
cadres à hauts salaires très élevés ould
abdi 1000 euros la retraite par
capitalisation et on peut se demander si
c
pas un projet je dirais plus globale
d'essayer de favoriser la prête par
capitalisation
alors ceci dit ambiant des sociétés
c'est un choix de société qui n'a pas
été clairement exprimée aux français et
pour lequel les chaussures naveen
empreinte de vérité
je suis d'accord que ça soit société qui
n'a pas été clairement exprimées et des
français ceci dit si on est d'accord
avec l'analyse de thomas piketty que le
taux de rendement au 21e siècle sera
plus élevé que le taux de croissance il
faut quand même faire attention à ne pas
forcément je dirais diaboliser la cape
la capitalisation en particulier au
niveau collectif personnellement je suis
pour que la france constitue un fonds
souverain comme le fait un grand pays
démocratique qui est qui et la norvège
parce que au cours du 21e siècle il peut
y avoir bien évidemment des crises
financières il peut y avoir bien
évidemment des crises économiques
il peut y avoir l'intelligence
artificielle qui réduit le poids des
salaires dans l'économie mais
fondamentalement le problème numéro un
que nous avons tous c'est le
réchauffement climatique et ce
réchauffement climatique peut avoir des
comptes et des conséquences inquiétantes
sur je dirais notre niveau de vie très
très très concrètement et donc il faut
je dirais faire en sorte que la france
puisse puiser dans un trésor accumulé
dans des dents cas dans des temps calmes
ce cas ce qu'a fait la norvège et y
compris pour payer les pensions qu'ils
ne pourraient plus être payés par le
système de répartition
donc je pense que la capitalisation ça
peut être une capitulation à titre
individuel sap est un titre disons de
l'ensemble des salariés est une
entreprise peut peut cotiser également
mais ça peut être aussi au niveau d'un
état au niveau de toute la nation
je rappelle qu'en 45 il ya une
hésitation entre le choix de la
capitalisation et le choix de la
répartition a aujourd'hui on nous
propose c'est surtout d'utiliser le
fonds de réserve des retraites pour
combler les trous à court terme
donc je pense pas qu'on aille vers ce
que vous proposez
et c'est bien les agréments du débat
c'est une grave erreur mais je pense que
là c'est une erreur profonde d'utiliser
les réserves actuelles au lieu
d'accumuler et d'essayer que ses
réserves face des petits au cas où il y
aurait des grosses difficultés et je
pense qu' il peut y avoir des grosses
difficultés au 21e siècle on aime on
terminera sur cet accord merci en tout
cas à vous on a appris plein de choses
pierre roger alain trannoy merci d'avoir
été avec nous à la veille de cette
grande journée de mobilisation alors que
votre syndicat demande une pause après
cette journée de mobilisation dans la
grève mais demandent toujours le retrait
bien évidemment du projet de réforme
merci à vous deux